und dieser mann ist nichts für schwache
nerven ein ums andere mal düpiert er
seine partner und verbündeten und lässt
sie seine macht spüren wenn sie ihn
nicht zu wählen sind was ihn nicht davon
abhält unablässig an der tür der
europäischen union zu klopfen um
eingelassen zu werden im dauerstreit mit
erdogan welche strategie hat der westen
jetzt
an der phoenix runde
phoenix runde
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen bei uns mal jetzt
zunächst im studio ist alle fuhren sie
sind chefreporterin von pioneer das ist
eine neue digitale nachrichtenplattform
die hier in berlin arbeitet und das ist
bei uns der leiter des zentrums für
angewandte türkeistudien
zugeschaltet aus ankara mustafa jener
rollo
abgeordneten im türkischen parlament für
die partei für demokratie und
fortschritt sie waren aber früher
abgeordnete für die akp die partei des
präsidenten erdogan und galten auch als
einer seiner vertrauten und professor
thomas jäger ist bei uns
politikwissenschaftler an der
universität köln herr jene rollo ist der
westen ich beziehe mich natürlich jetzt
auf diese sogenannte botschafter affäre
und die diskussion und die angedrohte
ausweisung nach einer solidarisierung
mit einem inhaftierten in der türkei ist
dieser ist der westen eine allzu leichte
beute für erdogan
nein so hat es glaube ich auch präsent
erbe war nicht
verstanden denn er hat den ernst der
lage schon sehr richtig eingeschätzt und
hat deswegen seine zunächst angekündigte
ausweisung der botschafter auch
zurückgezogen er hat nur versucht dabei
gesichtswahrend aus der situation
herauszukommen und ich müsste eigentlich
auch vor dem hintergrund sagen dass die
usa auch die anderen länder in ihm da
einen weg bereitet haben von daher die
türkei ist in einer schweren
wirtschaftlichen krise erfahren hat hat
versucht sich wie in früheren zeiten
auch als starker mann als
[Musik]
als jemand der das vaterland vor den
ausländischen mächten schützt
darzustellen in einem fall wo er
wirklich großes unrecht herrn kavala
gegenüber zu man kann jetzt letztendlich
darüber streiten ob das was die
botschafter in der form getan richtig
gewesen ist typisch gewesen ist aber
letztendlich in der sache hat denn die
botschafter recht ob das ist ihre
aufgabe war in der form sich in die
öffentlichkeit zu äußern darüber kann
man sich sicherlich streiten aber
letztendlich muss man auch wissen dass
kamera in die steinzeit ist geil in der
kooperation richtige gefühl ist jetzt
wie war das gleich nochmal genauer
besprechen verloren wir erleben immer
wieder dass erdogan skrupellos von
seiner macht gebrauch macht
kann man mit einem wie ihm überhaupt so
etwas wie verlässlichkeit entstehen
lassen
ich glaube ja und ich glaube dass man
auf jeden fall besser mit ihm arbeiten
kann als man es derzeit tut also die
frage ist ja welche strategie hat der
westen im umgang mit erdogan und mein
derzeitiges fazit wäre der westen hat
ganz offensichtlich gar keine strategie
ich halte diesen eklat um die zehn
botschafter wie er sich jetzt gerade
abgespielt hat für einen fehler dass
hätte gar nicht so weit kommen dürften
glaube ich und ich halte das was da
passiert ist für eine
wahlkampfhilfe für erdogan das ist kann
ich gleich auch noch gerne erläutern
weshalb aber ich halte es war ein fehler
dass sie so oft mit brief in der form so
veröffentlicht wurde das hat wenn jetzt
frau dran sagt dass man könnte das
eigentlich noch besser machen und das
verhältnis könnte sie besser sein könnte
man ja auch die frage stellen wo hat
denn der west die türkei vor den kopf
gestoßen dass diese reaktion vielleicht
in gewisser weise überhaupt die
reaktionen oder das verhaltene erdogan
es nicht nur in der botschaft der krise
irgendwie auch so ein bisschen
nachvollziehbar ist
dann müssen wir glaube ich sehr lange
zurück gehen nämlich so in die 2010er
2011 elf jahre als in der türkei die
dynamik der der reformen zu ende
gekommen ist weil die akp die
regierungspartei das erste mal wirklich
fest im sattel saß und nichts mehr zu
befürchten hatte vom militär oder von
der hohen justiz dies als
außerparlamentarische vetomächte öfters
eingegriffen haben es gab sogar mal
einen antrag auf parteiverbot auch
butter kaffee und 2011 hat diese dynamik
nachgelassen und da hat die europäische
union eigentlich oder hätte sie
eigentlich gas geben müssen und auf die
türkei zu gehen müssen um diesen mit
wirtschaftsprozess der ein reformmotor
gewesen ist um den aufrecht zu erhalten
das arbeitsfenster ist in dem moment
angeschlossen gewesen findet dann ist in
diesem moment geschlossen worden und
damals hatte war erdogan sicher zu recht
frustriert ob er heute noch ein recht
hat über den westen frustriert zu sein
nach all dem was er in den letzten
jahren gezeigt hat würde ich verneinte
er jäger gibt es denn eigentlich
überhaupt noch gemeinsame interessen
zwischen dem westen und der türkei
ja die gibt es und die türkei spielt
ihre stellung die sie nach dem ende des
ost-west-konflikts gewonnen hat und die
sich danach sozusagen immer weiter
ausgebildet hat eben aus sie ist
sozusagen ein akteur der sich als
unerlässlich an sieht und für manche
auch unerlässlich ist um partner der
großen mächte zu sein deswegen kann sich
präsident erdogan so viel erlauben weil
die strategie die alle staaten der
partei gegenüber verfolgen und jetzt
können wir streiten ob passende
strategie ist einfach heißt nur nicht
ganz den kontakt verlieren nur die
türkei nicht in das lager der gegner
drängen und die geostrategische lage der
türkei das ist sozusagen das ass im
ärmel mit dem er ständig spielen kann
herr jene rollo vielleicht gestatten sie
mir noch kurz eine persönliche frage ich
habe schon gesagt sie waren früher in
der akp gewesen jetzt haben sie eine
eigene partei gegründet sind weiterhin
mitglied im türkischen parlament warum
sind sie denn eigentlich
ausgestiegen bei erdogan sie galten ja
so als sprachrohr erdogan in deutschland
ich bin 2015 im juni schmerzen markt
gewählt worden dann haben wir neu waren
drei monate später gehabt im november
2015 und anschließend hatte er mich
gebeten den vorsitz der
menschenrechtskommission des parlamentes
zu übernehmen was ich dann auch gemacht
habe und nicht die letztendlich
tagtäglich mit den schweren fehlern die
die exekutive zu verantworten hat
insbesondere in menschenrechtsfragen im
allgemeinen in fragen der
rechtsstaatlichkeit und demokratie
schwund beschäftigen musste und das hat
damit angefangen dass ich permanent
strafanzeigen gegen hohe beamte
einreichen musste wegen
unterstützung oder nicht verfolgung von
folter von anderen schweren verbrechen
aus meiner sicht starke vergehen aus
meiner sicht und das hat letztendlich
dazu geführt dass quasi immer wieder die
auseinandersetzung mit dem innenminister
spd mann sollte der machen vor den
posten innehat
zur situation geführt hat die immer
wieder verloren gelangen gelandet sind
ich habe mich nicht zurückgenommen habe
gesagt dass ich den posten als
vorsitzender menschenrechtskommission
gerne abgeben aber letztendlich meine
sozialisation meine vorstellung von
rechtsstaatlichkeit und demokratie mehr
gebieten immer wieder darauf zu pochen
das diak partei auf ihre ursprüngliche
auf ihre ursprünge auf ihre wurzeln
zurück geht es ging nicht um inhaltliche
um inhaltliche fragen sondern es ging um
auseinandersetzung oder das zerwürfnis
hatte
menschenrechtspolitische ursachen
ja ich habe natürlich in denen in
derzeit tagtäglich feststellen müssen
dass wir
permanent
permanent rechtsstaatliche vorstellungen
quasi
von uns
entfernen demokratie vorstellungen wie
ich sie mir auch in deutschland
angeeignet habe hier von tag zu tag
[Musik]
probleme bereiten wie ich sie in der
öffentlichkeit vertreten habe und das
hat er auch immer wieder zu
auseinandersetzungen in der
öffentlichkeit mit der bahn geführt in
dem fall kavala nach dem putschversuch
im jahre
2016 wo ich mich auch immer wieder
vehement in der türkischen
öffentlichkeit gegen
menschenrechtsverletzungen
gewandt habe und irgendwann ging das
natürlich nicht mehr so dass ich
eigentlich bereit war 2018 zu
kandidieren aber deswegen haben wir
gesprochen
den namen kavala schon genannt osman
kavala das ist der anlass für diese
auseinandersetzung zwischen der türkei
und den zehn ländern deren botschafter
die freilassung gefordert haben und
nicht nur die botschafter aus ankara
einen
kultur mit 10 der sich in der türkei
sehr stark engagiert sie haben jetzt
schon gesagt das war verloren das war so
eine art unfreiwilliger wahlkampf viel
für eigentlich für erdogan irgendwann in
den nächsten 18 monaten sind ja wahlen
parlamentswahlen der türkei
um das wissenschafts malen die frage ist
warum protestieren botschafter gegen
eine sicherlich ungerechte inhaftierung
aus unserer sicht um nach einer
erwartbaren schnellen empörung der
türkischen seite einen offensichtlichen
rückzieher zu machen haben sie dafür
eine erklärung
um ehrlich zu sein nicht und genau das
würde ich unterstreichen was sie gerade
gesagt haben dass nämlich dann einen
rückzieher gemacht wurde also nachdem
dieser offene brief veröffentlicht wurde
war das ja eben aus meiner sicht die
vollkommen ideale wahlkampfhilfe weil
dann erdogan sowieso im moment in einer
innenpolitisch sehr schwierigen lage ist
die wirtschaftslage ist katastrophal die
währung liegt bei 1
11 euro zu einem euro elf lehrer zu
einem euro das heißt erdogan ist wieder
einmal in dieser situation in der er
feinde braucht und normalerweise richtet
er sich dann meistens genau
normalerweise richtet er sich dann gegen
kurden gegen alle bieten gegen die lgbt
gemeinde also es gibt genug minderheiten
die für so etwas dann herhalten dürfen
das war diesmal nicht nötig denn die
hilfe kamen aus dem besten in form
dieses offenen brief ist und ich frage
mich eine solche aktion muss sich ja
immer daran messen lassen ob sie ihrem
vorhaben näher gekommen ist und ich
würde eher sagen dass man sich davon
sind noch weiter entfernt hat also aus
meiner kamera hat man damit ganz sicher
kein würde sagen das ist also kultur mit
zehn liessmann philanthrop also
menschenfreund eigentlich eine ganz
sympathische figuren der wird er wie ein
staatsfeind behandelt warum ist das so
also seinen ursprung hat das ja genommen
bei den geopark protesten ihnen wird ja
vorgeworfen dass er im rahmen der
gegenproteste spionage agenten artige
handlungen durchführt hätte dass er an
einer die stabilisierung des staates
beteiligt wäre dann hat man das auch
noch verknüpft mit dem putschversuch und
2017 hat man ihnen dann festgenommen
gleichzeitig ist aus meinem kavala aber
nicht nur kultur mit zielen sondern auch
unternehmer es heißt es soll ja auch
noch andere bedürfnisse zwischen
tatsächlich dem präsidenten erkoren und
osman kavala persönlich gehen es geht um
rüstungsdeals um die um die lieferung
eines panzers dass erdogan dann wem
anders gegeben hat nämlich der coach
holding gruppe daraufhin ob das kausal
zusammenhängt oder nicht jedenfalls hat
sich aus man kavala sehr früh gegen als
es um eine änderung des systems ging hin
zum präsidialsystem hat sich aus man
kann man dagegen ausgesprochen de facto
gibt es keine wirklichen beweise für
moßmann kavala schuld deswegen sitzt er
unschuldig ist ein aus meiner sicht vor
allem persönliches ziel
russland putin und der sich auch mit
einigen bereichen überworfen hat da
spielten auch unternehmerische und
wirtschaftliche gründe eine rolle
jetzt hat er das europäische der
europäische gerichtshof ja gesagt herr
kavala sei frei zu lassen das war im mai
letzten jahres dass es sei derzeit nicht
erfolgt der europarat hat jetzt eine
ultimatum bis ende november gestellt
was passiert eigentlich wenn die türkei
dieses ultimatum missachtet dann wird
wird die wie die die stimmrechte der
türkei im europarat suspendiert das ist
der erste schritt aber lassen sie mich
kurz sagen dass ich mit frau dauern da
nicht übereinstimmen muss man kavala ist
unternehmer das ist richtig hat seit
sicher 20 25 jahren kulturarbeit
gefördert vor allen dingen den ausgleich
zwischen verschiedenen identitäten
kurden aleviten und sunniten säkulare
und
ihnen jetzt er hat das alles getan auch
auf kosten eigentlich seiner
unternehmerischen seines
unternehmerischen erfolgs und in hier in
einem atemzug mit russischen oligarchen
zu nehmen die aufgrund wirtschaftlicher
ich hätte
einen präsidenten und ein autokrat sich
häufig daneben in wirtschaftlichen
bereichen wichtigen leuten über wirft ja
aber erst einmal muss ein kabbalah hat
sein unternehmen war nie von einer so
zentralen bedeutung für den türkischen
staat dass er zum beispiel eine gefahr
für den türkischen staat gewährt
geworden wäre wie dass die oligarchen in
russland zum beispiel für input hätten
sein können und er war auch innerhalb
der unternehmerschaft ein begehren der
eine außergewöhnliche figur der nicht
versucht hat jetzt die unternehmerschaft
gegen gegen erdogan zu formieren oder
hier in der opposition aufzubauen ich
denke dass der grund für den
dafür dass das ein kabbalah in die auf
die zielscheibe von von von herrn
erdogan geraten ist dass er weiter
zurück liegt nämlich als der zu der zeit
2013 ist zwischen 2015 sie wissen da hat
das eine initiative gegeben in der
türkei zum ausgleich mit den kurden zu
kommen zum ausgleich mit der pkk zu
kommen und damals hatte sich
abgezeichnet als möglichkeit das
kulturelle rechte für die kurden
gewährt werden würden vielleicht sogar
stärkere regionale selbstverwaltung eine
stärkung der vormonat der kommunen der
kritischen kommunen und das aber
gleichzeitig sich die autoritäre
tendenzen der türkischen abgezeichnet
hatte und linke und liberale in der
türkei hatten gewarnt davor dass es
praktisch ein deal gibt zwischen der pkk
und wurden lasst uns unsere unser
kleines herrschaftsgebiet haben und wir
sind da wir werden nicht opponieren
gegen eine zunehmend autoritäre
herrschaft über den restlichen drei und
das war so viel ich weiß aus meinem
körper lage der gegen diese möglichkeit
sehr stark sich ausgesprochen hat weil
er geglaubt hat dass es eine gesamte
demokratisierung der türkei braucht eine
lösung des kurdenproblems einfach
gleichzeitig die demokratisierung und er
hat damit diesen entwurf diesen plan von
herr du haben eigentlich zum scheitern
gebracht ich denke das ist der grund
besonders für die darstellung denn das
war er bei uns oder ist bei uns viele
nicht klar auch jetzt klar dadurch
geworden wie es zu dieser eskalation
kommen konnte
thomas jäger wenn es jetzt wirklich
wiederholt frage nochmal ich gerade so
wird auch schon gestellt habe wenn ich
jetzt wirklich zu dem eklat kommt dass
man die mitgliedschaft der türkei im
europarat suspendiert ist das vielleicht
etwas was erdogan ganz zupass kommt oder
ist das ein weiterer baustein eines
zerwürfnisses dass sich immer weiter
eskaliert zwischen dem westen und der
türkei
die eskalation zwischen dem westen und
der türkei geht ja sozusagen immer hin
und her es gab schon schlimmere momente
es gibt jetzt wieder charme offensiven
jetzt ist ist die frage wie geht man mit
dieser situation um und
vermutlich wird die wird versucht werden
eben auch
wiederum eine politik zu treiben die die
türkei zwar erinnert daran was sie zu
tun hätte aber sie gleichzeitig nicht
bestraft denn das ist ja das was die
europäische union die auch in anderen
fällen den konflikt mit der türkei steht
seit geraumer zeit tut und auch das hat
eben seinen grund darin dass man die
türkei als einen eigenständigen staat
ansehen musste man als partner nicht
verlieren will die türkei hat sich vom
westen entfremdet und das ist ja im
prozess der bis in die 70er jahre zurück
reicht sie sieht ihre sicherheit nicht
mehr durch den westen gewährleistet und
eigentlich mal präsident r gewann nur
konsequente politik auf der grundlage
dessen was auch die deutsche
außenpolitik denkt wenn man liest was
sie sagt nämlich dass sich die welt in
eine multipolare ordnung entwickelt das
heißt es gibt mehrere große mächte und
er ist bestrebt darin neben dem platz
der türkei zu suchen um die sicherheit
des regimes die sicherheit des landes zu
gewährleisten
und da ist ein mittel eben der
politischen einfluss zu suchen den er im
geografischen umfeld der türkei sucht
und scheut dabei keinen konflikt mit all
denjenigen mit denen er sonst geschäft
gemacht oder gute beziehungen pflegt wir
wollen auf die globale und
außenpolitische dimension gleich noch
mal zurückgekommen halo wir haben es ja
jetzt schon gehört dass der vermutet die
eskalation in diesem streit mit den
botschaftern das hat eigentlich in
politische gründe möglicherweise ein
ablenkungsmanöver wir hören dass die
türkische wirtschaft auf talfahrt ist es
gibt eine gewaltige inflation im land
der die türkische währung der lira wird
immer schwächer das verteuert die
importe in die türkei die türkei ist als
rohstoffarmes land sehr abhängig von
importen dh das jagt erst recht die
inflation nach oben
wie ist denn die situation im moment wie
in stimmung die politische die soziale
die ökonomische situation in ihrem land
von tag zu tag schlechter die offizielle
inflationsrate beträgt etwa 20 aber
tatsächlich dürfte sie über 35 40
prozent gegen insbesondere was die
preissteigerung bei lebensmitteln
anbetrifft darüber hinaus ist es so dass
insbesondere jugendlichen sehr stark von
arbeitslosigkeit betroffen sind
offiziell liegt die zahl
bei 25 prozent aber inoffiziell müssten
wieder an die 30 35 prozent sein
insgesamt befindet sich die türkische
wirtschaft auf talfahrt
gerade die
devisen die jetzt seit einem jahr und 20
prozent gestiegen sind haben dazu
geführt dass insbesondere die menschen
die sowieso sehr wenig zum leben habe
gerade im letzten jahr um 20 30 prozent
an armut zugenommen habe und das führt
dazu dass die menschen natürlich von tag
zu tag auch gegenüber der regierung ihre
proteste steigern ich bin letzte woche
in trabzon gewesen am schwarzmeer eine
hochburg eigentlich von ärger und musste
dort in einem kleinen ort wo die aktei
bei den letzten wahl noch an die 80
prozent geholt war hat feststellen im
gespräch mit über 200 dortigen klein
geschäftsinhaber dass die dass der dass
der wut der menschen gegen erdogan
gegenüber von tag zu tag zugenommen
hatte also bis vor sechs monaten hatten
wir noch eine andere situation
50 60 prozent der jugendlichen die derag
partei ihre stimmen geben würden nicht
mehr in der türkei leben weil den
umfragen ist es grundsätzlich so dass
über 60 prozent der türkischen
jugendlichen von einem leben im
europäischen ausland träumen deshalb das
land ist im moment in einer
katastrophalen wirtschaftlichen
situation und die leute wissen das ist
nicht besser
darin wird denn damit es besser wird
damit die türkei wieder investitionen
aus dem ausland bekommen wie der direkte
bewiesen ins land fließen musste ich
muss das land wieder eben zurück zur
demokratie zurück zu recht jetzt kann
man ja sagen dass er
bei jena rollo war für die
wirtschaftliche situation jetzt mal
ansehen ist könnte ich alle türkischen
jugendlichen die gerne in europa leben
wollen hat ihn aber europa könnte ja der
türkei auch unter die arme greifen als
handelspartner auch das ja probleme mit
der zollunion ist das eine möglichkeit
der sich vielleicht auch der westen und
die türkei wieder etwas annähert wenn es
zu besseren handels und
wirtschaftsbeziehungen kommt die dann
letztendlich ja der türkei auch helfen
aus dieser gravierenden wirtschaftskrise
herauszukommen
ich glaube das ist ein ganz wichtiger
punkt in die machen und ich glaube dass
eine muss man gar nicht so sehr von dem
anderen trennen ich glaube worauf sich
die politik in der eu in deutschland im
westen sozusagen auch einlassen muss ist
dass man mit erdogan durchaus und die
erfahrung hat man ja auch schon gemacht
die es machen kann das heißt man kann ja
sagen ihr wollt die ausweitung der
türkei zollunion ok dann lasst uns über
menschenrechte sprechen dann lasst uns
über zu unrecht inhaftierte sprechen
dann können wir über einen erasmus
programm sprechen dann können wir über
die lockerung der visa verfahren
sprechen also mit diesem quid pro quo
mit dieser quid pro quo art von politik
kommt man mit recep tayyip erdogan
glaube ich schon ganz weit und da der
diät ganz gerne genau und das kann man
sich natürlich zu nutze machen nur das
geht nicht mit einer art von
symbolpolitik und offenen briefen die
botschafter veröffentlichen und ich
glaube auch dass oder ich fände es toll
wenn wir auch anfangen zu unterscheiden
zwischen person erdogan zwischen
akp-regierung und zwischen
zivilgesellschaft bevölkerung und
überhaupt das land als solches auch da
werden wir viel zu oft immer alles in
einen job gerade jetzt wo wir 60 jahre
jubiläum des abwerbe anwerbeabkommens
feiern würde ich mich freuen wenn wir
versuchen die nähe tatsächlich zu heizen
weiter auszubauen und dabei trotzdem
noch alle unsere verzögerung der lange
zeit hinter sich ja der relativ
erfolgreich als volkstribun auch
wahlkampf immer gemacht
nein in der jetzt auch in der türkei ist
ja auch immer wieder gewählt ja aber ich
glaube was eine jener ohne gesagt hat
das dürfen wir nicht unterschätzen
es gab ja es gab ständig krisen und
skandale und e-class zwischen der eu und
deutschland und der türkei im moment
glaube ich erleben wir eine schon
einzigartige zeit denn noch nie ging es
erdogan tatsächlich machtpolitisch so
schlecht noch nie hatte er so schlechte
umfragen von den unter 25-jährigen dem
gerade einmal elf prozent an sie würden
die akp bei der nächsten wahl wählen und
in der türkei habe mir eine etwas andere
demografische situation ist sind einige
unter 25 jährige das heißt im moment ist
es wirklich schlecht um ihn gestellt
nicht nur erdogan gilt gerne das tun die
europäische union auch da kommt fällt
ein deal sofort ins auge zu unserem
vorteil der das flüchtlings abkommen der
türkei da fließen zwar viele milliarden
in die türkei andererseits aber bleiben
millionen von flüchtlingen dann in der
türkei werden dort versorgt werden dort
auch zum teil auch integriert zu haben
habe ich zugang zur gesundheits und
bildungseinrichtungen
wird dieses abkommen das uns ja so
wichtig ist sich jetzt auch auf mögliche
andere probleme die in der migration
demnächst auftreten können auch andere
fluchtwege wird dieses abkommen in der
türkei das ja auch der europäischen
union geholfen hat für das halten unter
den bedingungen die wir gerade
diskutieren es wird schwieriger es zu
halten weil die opposition in den
letzten wochen und monaten eigentlich
den letzten wochen eher das thema in
gewisser weise entdeckt hat gerade
angesichts des rückzugs der amerikaner
und ihrer verbündeten aus afghanistan um
es große befürchtungen gab das nun aus
afghanistan große flüchtlingswellen
kommen und die türkei wieder einer der
staaten ist die dem flüchtlings oder
diesen migrationsdruck am stärksten
ausgesetzt sind es wird also schwieriger
das zu halten ist wird auch schwieriger
weil eben die kommunikationskanäle immer
immer dünner werden man muss aber glaube
ich zwei dinge auch sagen in der türkei
diejenigen die in der türkei mit
flüchtlingen arbeiten sehen dieses
abkommen als ein erfolg an auch in der
europäischen union man sagt immer
eingeladen ist ein schmutziger deal aber
die stimmung ist natürlich so dass
niemand mehr flüchtlinge will von daher
glaube ich gibt es also auch eine
anerkennung dass dieses abkommen wichtig
ist und es gibt noch ein zweites
angesichts gerade der
angst dass mehr flüchtlinge aus
afghanistan kommen haben wir in der
türkei genau dieselbe diskussion nämlich
die externalisierung des
flüchtlingsproblems das heißt auch die
türkei sagt jetzt die flüchtlinge
bleiben aus afghanistan die bleiben am
besten in pakistan und im iran weil
lassen die lebenshaltungskosten
niedriger und da können wir mit dem
gleichen finanziellen einsatz viel mehr
flüchtlingen hätten reichen quasi das
geld noch ein stück weiter dann ja du
hast das ist das ist die das ist der
mechanismus das ist aber auch natürlich
eine realistische politik weil es gibt
einfach begrenzte mittel es gibt eine
begrenzte bereitschaft die wir auch in
der türkei sehen die sehr viele
flüchtlinge haben das geprägt der
begrenzte bereitschaft noch mehr
flüchtlinge aufzunehmen gerade im winder
befahren ist ja eigentlich gegen die
flüchtlinge zeigt seit kurzer zeit dass
die bevölkerung hat sehr sehr lange das
mitgetragen aus bewundernswerter
solidarität ich denke aber auch dass da
natürlich die das hohe ansehen von
präsident erdogan in den jahren davor
eine große rolle gespielt hat jetzt wo
sein ansehen sinkt nimmt man natürlich
auch er zur kenntnis dass die
unterbringung der flüchtlinge natürlich
auch ein preis hat zum beispiel im
arbeitsmarkt zum beispiel im
wohnungsmarkt zum beispiel was die löhne
betrifft es geht eher um die
lebensumstände die sich verändert haben
und weniger um das ansehen er dort das
glaube ich nicht gut dass man muss ja
auch sagen ist glaube ich über 5
millionen flüchtlinge die in den letzten
jahren in die türkei gekommen vielleicht
noch eins hat ja weil weil sie ganz
sicher zu recht gesagt haben man müsste
mehr deals machen die europäische union
hat er seit 2008 zehn eigentlich gesagt
wir sind bereits bereit über die
vertiefung und erweiterung der zollunion
zu sprechen mit der türkei genau unter
der voraussetzung dass es schritte hin
zur demokratisierung gibt und das hat
eben nicht gewirkt also der deal oder
das angebot an erdogan besteht seit 2008
zehn darf seit damals gibt es diesen
beschluss des europäischen rates und
erdogan ist nicht darauf eingegangen das
heißt die frage ist auch wie wichtig ist
das für ihn wir wissen dass die
exportindustrie die nach deutschland und
in euro nach europa exportiert dem
produzierende industrie die ist vor
allen dingen in den händen der alten
säkularen elite aber erdogan hat sich
eine neue industrie geschaffen herr
jener ole weiß das besser als ich
infrastruktur energie rüstungsindustrie
und deren interessen sind eben nicht
primär damit gedient wenn die zu landen
wenn das stichwort vertiefung und
erweiterung feld professor jäger dann
denkt man natürlich sofort auch an den
eu beitritt der türkei das ist ja
eigentlich durch ein abkommen aus dem
jahr
zugesagt worden es wird zwei jahren seit
jahrzehnten darüber verhandelt die eu
kommission hat aus diesem grund auch
jedes jahr einen bericht über den stand
der beitrittsverhandlungen
veröffentlicht kein wunder vor kurzem
wieder veröffentlicht worden dass die eu
kommission zu einem vernichtenden urteil
kommt über den stand der
rechtsstaatlichkeit in der türkei da
fragt man sich ja eigentlich was gibt es
da noch zu verhandeln in bezug auf einen
irgendwann stattfinden sollen den
eu-beitritt der türkei
das thema ist für alle praktischen
zwecke vom tisch und was er soll hat
eben gesagt hat ist ja völlig richtig
das primäre interesse der türkischen
regierung ist die regime sicherheit im
eigenen land und die sicherheit des
staates in einem ja doch sich sehr
wandelnden noch zum teil gewaltsamen
umfeld und da gibt es keinen preis der
so hoch ist dass man in der lage wäre
die türkische regierung in diese
richtung zu bewegen was man machen kann
was er in den vereinigten staaten und
auch in der eu diskutiert wird ist zu
sehen wie es sind dann prioritäten so
gelagert werden was interesse wie kommt
man wirklich ins gespräch miteinander
und wenn man sich das anschaut dann wird
man doch sagen müssen die prioritäten
sind sehr unterschiedlich die
europäische union hat ein besonderes
interesse an migration das ist eben
besprochen worden da wäre noch zu sagen
man hat hier sozusagen einer
erfolgreichen weg gefunden aber dem
präsidenten eben auch ein mittel in die
hand gegeben dass er anwenden kann und
dass ihr dann sozusagen im vorhinein
reflektiert wird hoch was passiert wenn
er das tut es gibt die
auseinandersetzung um ressourcen im
östlichen mittelmeer wo die europäische
union auch sozusagen nur halb dass ihr
mitglied griechenland unterstützt hat so
dass frankreich vorgeprescht ist und
gesagt hat man muss da intensiver der
türkei einhalt gebieten die vereinigten
staaten haben insbesondere interesse
daran dass die türkei
doch nicht dass in russland gekaufte
raketenabwehrsystem nutzt und das
irgendwie vom tisch kommt und versucht
das momentan als nato problem zu
deklarieren um die europäer hier mit ins
boot zu holen und an das ist aber aus
sicht der türkischen regierung sozusagen
nur zweitrangig weil es im ersten punkt
um regimes sicherheit geht im zweiten
punkt um den einfluss in der region und
im dritten darum zu den sicher aus
bildenden neuen kosmischen den usa
russland und china eben ganz
einträgliche beziehungen zu führen ohne
sich von irgendeiner groß machen
wirklich abhängig zu machen rollo wenn
man das hört die akten die unterlagen
zur verhandlung über einen eu beitritt
kann man die ohne mit der wimper zu
zucken ins historische archiv stecken
weil einfach der eu beitritt aus der
zeit gefallen ist er ist nicht mehr
aktuell der ist nicht mehr gegenstand
von realen politischen verhandlungen
weil inzwischen andere schwerpunkte
wichtig sind im verhältnis des westens
zur türkei
also aus meiner sicht kann ich natürlich
verstehen dass der prozess schon seit
langem eigentlich auf eis gelegt ist ich
verstehe dass das jetzt nicht die
aufgefrischt werden kann aber
letztendlich ist es auch in der
verantwortung von europa dass die
beziehungen zur türkei nicht weiter
abbrechen auch die türkische
gesellschaft hat ein interesse daran
dass die beziehungen nicht sich weiter
verschlechtert sondern irgendwann wird
es
meiner vorstellung nach so weit sein
dass wir in der türkei die
zivilgesellschaft so weit sind dass wir
wieder konkret die kapitel die noch
nicht abgeschlossen sind angehen und
andere kapitel die wir noch nicht
geöffnet haben auch zu öffnen so dass
die beziehungen zur eu nicht abbreche
abgebrochen werden dürfen und man
einfach zu den neuen wahlen abwarten
muss ich glaube dass eben aber nicht
mehr in der lage ist in der türkei eine
wahl zu gewinnen und die die
demokratischen kräfte in der türkei
versuchen sich gegenwärtig zu verbinden
es gibt sicherlich viele
herausforderungen aber alle parteien in
der opposition sind im moment der
überzeugung dass man nur gemeinsam
handeln gegen erbach
die wahlen gewinnen kann damit die
türkei nicht weiter in fragen von
demokratie und rechtsstaatlichkeit zu
einem noch autoritären noch des
unsicheren start wird dass wir im moment
fernab von jeglicher verfassungs
vorstellung wer fernab von jeglicher
rechtlicher vorstellung in der pp
regiert werden das ist
jetzt darüber braucht man nicht mehr zu
diskutieren das ist fakt aber ich glaube
dass die beziehungen zu europa doch so
wichtig sind dass auch die gegenwärtige
situation
zumindest eben die hoffnung am tag
erhält dass wir demnächst darauf
aufbauen können und dass sich noch
schlimmer wird gut das heißt also dass
wenn ich jetzt an jene richtig
verstanden habe wenn man das system
erdogan überwunden hat also eine
rückkehr zur demokratie und
rechtsstaatlichkeit dann bekäme die
europäische perspektive der türkei eine
neue chance ist dass real ist erleben
wir dass in diesem jahrzehnt noch
also der glaube ich ist es auf jeden
fall ich glaube der wunsch in der
türkischen bevölkerung ist schon nahe
ich glaube aber dass es ein bisschen
dauern könnte bis auch manche wunden
heilen unabhängig davon ob die jetzt
bericht berechtigt sind oder nicht
unabhängig davon ob das ein falscher
stolz ist ja gerade gekränkt ist oder
nicht ich glaube schon dass er eine
entfremdung stattgefunden hat bei der es
etwas dauern könnte bis man wieder so
ist wie vielleicht anfang der 2000er
jahre und ich glaube einfach dass es im
moment ein ganz ganz kritischer punkt
ist in der türkei und ich würde gar
nicht so sehr vom westen erwarten dass
er dieses oder jenes tut um da
irgendwelche
demokratisierungsprozesse zu
unterstützen mir würde schon reichen
wenn sie nichts tun um die was dann auch
noch dazu führt dass ist in politisch
ausgeschlachtet werden kann das heißt
ich glaube so ein bisschen zurückhaltung
werden gar nicht so schlecht zumindest
was die politische was das einmischen in
innenpolitischen dinge angeht und dann
mal abwarten was bei eventuellen bayern
passiert und währenddessen das noch
wirklich wirklich versuchen trotzdem die
zivilgesellschaft zu stützen mit allen
möglichen programme wie wohl das
anwerbeabkommen
561 angesprochen das hat ja massive
konsequenzen gehabt viele
türkischstämmige menschen also kein
gekommen sind leben schon der dritten
oder vierten generation jetzt hier haben
sie die deutsche staatsbürgerschaft
angenommen die doppelte
staatsbürgerschaft das heißt die
verbindung zur türkei sind einem nicht
unerheblichen teil unserer bevölkerung
außerordentlich intensiv doch da kann es
uns ja eigentlich nicht egal sein wie
die beziehungen zur türkei sich
weiterentwickeln ist das auch für uns
wird eine notwendigkeit möglicherweise
jetzt auch für die neue bundesregierung
darum wieder einen neuen ansatz zu
finden
dass das sozusagen nicht völlig aus der
aus der sicht verschwindet dass diese
scheidung auf raten die man so manchmal
hat das gefühl dass das wirklich nicht
stattfindet gerade im verhältnis
deutschland türkei also das ist
unbedingt eine notwendigkeit die
türkischstämmige bevölkerung hier ist
groß sie ist stark ich würde nicht sagen
dass es einfach nur massive konsequenzen
hatte das klingt so ein bisschen fast
schon negativ so dass millionen von
menschen wie dieser migrationsgeschichte
inzwischen hier leben und dass diese
menschen sozusagen genauso mit dem
deutschen wirtschaftswunder zu tun haben
wie umgekehrt und insofern glaube ich
haben wir schon das erbe und setzt auch
dieser beziehung zwischen diesen beiden
staaten zu stellen und auch darum bemüht
zu sein dass es eine gute beziehung ist
weil eben wir mittlerweile glaube ich
sehr viele wirklich symbiotische
identitäten in deutschland haben und
wenn deutschland und die türkei ein
problem miteinander haben dann ist das
auch ein innerdeutsches problem
das heißt dieses verhältnis deutschland
türkei ist noch ein ganz spezielles ist
in deutschland sich dieser verantwortung
gerade auch für die menschen die hierher
gekommen sind die hier leben auch
bewusst auch in seinem umgang mit der
türkei oder gibt es da defizite ist da
noch luft nach oben
also ich denke dass das richtige nicht
dass wir politik machen sollten aufgrund
von identitäten und auch leute oder die
bevölkerung sollte nicht primär
politiker kommt von identitäten sondern
von von interessen machen und ich denke
schon dass sich die bundesregierung ihre
verantwortung den typischen
mitgliedern den den mit den bürgern mit
mit türkischen nutzen gegenüber bewusst
ist aber das spielt sich meiner meinung
nach eher
inclusive inclusive inklusiven
bildungspolitik in einer
arbeitsmarktpolitik in der sozialpolitik
ab ich denke nicht dass wir sagen
sollten wir müssen unsere verhältnis
unserer verhängnis unter gray auf eine
bestimmte art und weise gestalten weil
wir einen großen anzeige
türkischstämmiger mitbürger hier haben
weil das klingt immer so als wenn die
beziehungen schief gehen dann machen
diese mitbürger und probleme das ist
immer so ein bisschen übertrieben aber
diese mitbürger auch einzuladen eben das
versucht er und genau das wird
wahrgenommen oder das ist genau dieses
dieses bild wenn wir die beziehungen der
türkei zu konflikt haft fahren dann
haben wir in deutschland probleme und
das ist stellt mittlerweile eigentlich
auch die türkische bevölkerung unter
seinen verdacht dass die letzten endes
bereit wären sich instrumentalisieren zu
lassen und ich denke das sollten wir das
sollten wir nicht tun aber natürlich
haben wir sehr enge beziehungen wir
haben nicht nur die türkische
einwanderung nach deutschland wir haben
nicht nur die die flüchtlings
zusammenarbeit sondern wir haben auch
wahnsinnig enge wirtschaftsbeziehungen
und die deutsche industrie ist
angewiesen auf funktionierende
lieferketten in der türkei wir haben
sehr sehr viele investitionen in
deutschland aus deutschland in der
türkei langfristige investitionen im
produzierenden bereich die nicht von
heute auf morgen zurück gezogen werden
können oder woanders hin verlagert
werden können deswegen hat die deutsche
wirtschaft und der deutsche staat ein
interesse daran dass die beziehungen mit
der türkei nicht noch schlechter werden
und ich denke das ist auch ein legitimes
interesse und andere ein anderes ich
denke wir sind einfach in einer
schwierigen position weil es ist
natürlich richtig wenn wenn frau dann
wenn sie sagen irgendwie die
zivilgesellschaft unterstützen aber herr
kavala ist praktisch das gesicht der
türkischen zivilgesellschaft heute und
er sitzt im gefängnis und von daher
denke ich schon dass es richtig ist dass
wir uns für ihn einsetzen und ich denke
nicht dass
ich denke auch nicht mehr die form dass
diese aktion der botschafter so
verheerend war mal wie sich selbst
gesagt haben herr erdogan hat jederzeit
die möglichkeit über lgbt community über
aleviten über kurden über den einmarsch
über eine neue operation in syrien oder
im irak über eine eskalation im
östlichen mittelmeer die bevölkerung
hinter sich zu bringen wenn wir uns zu
gefangenen machen der möglichkeit dass
erdogan das ausnutzt dann finden wir uns
die hand ich denke was wir gesehen haben
bei dieser botschafter aktionär hat ein
stück weit auch nach gegeben er hat
gesagt diese leute werden ausgewiesen
sie würden nicht ausgewiesen und dass
diese ablenkungsmanöver die
funktionieren wenn die leute wirklich
ein stück weit mit der lage zufrieden
sind aber was wir von herrn jene herodot
gehört haben dass die unzufriedenheit
aufgrund der wirtschaftlichen situation
und es ist eine wirtschaftliche
situation ist so schlecht ist weil
dieses präsidialsystem einfach nicht
funktioniert weil er da war nichts von
der wirtschaft versteht aber die
wirtschaft bestimmt weil er letzten
endes die diplomaten praktisch zur seite
auf die seite geschoben hat und die
diplomatie nicht funktioniert weil er
dann die türkei im östlichen mittelmeer
isoliert ist weil sie nicht weiß wir
sind syrien weiter gehen soll und dieses
bild von einer türkei die an die wand
gefahren worden ist das ist da in der
bevölkerung ich glaube nicht dass solche
ablenkungsmanöver das die nach bevor
jetzt die wähler sehr stark beeinflussen
ich weiß nicht fasst all jene uhr denkt
aber da können wir dann auch gleich
sagen ich würde gerne mit einer mit
einer frage noch verbinden hat jonas
sind gleich am ende der sendung
untertitel der sendung lautet der hat
der westen eine strategie gegenüber der
türkei hat er eine oder und wie müsste
die vor allen dingen aussehen
also der westen eine strategie gegen die
türkei ich halte von dieser
begrifflichkeit eigentlich auch wenig
was heißt westen was heißt die türkei
ich würde
ich bin immer bemüht wenn diese im
gegensatz die ja immer so als
tatsächlich kite dargestellt wird zu
entkräften ich glaube nicht dass es
das dass das in dieser form gibt erdogan
versucht was so darzustellen aber sowohl
die typische community in deutschland in
westeuropa und das sind etwa sechs
millionen menschen
denn wenn man eben die
die anderen europäischen länder wie
niederlande frankreich england holland
und so weiter doch die bevölkerung dazu
rechnet die menschen leben im westen die
sind teil des westens 50 60 prozent der
türkischen gesellschaft mindestens 50 60
prozent der türkischen gesellschaft
würden auch heute trotz der extrem
zugenommen einen
extrem zugenommen autoritären
unterstützung in der gesellschaft trotz
der den steigenden nationalismus in der
türkei für eine vollmitgliedschaft bei
der eu stimmen und ich glaube deswegen
sollten wir tatsächlich
interessenpolitik auch aus europäischer
sicht aber auch aus hübsch ist es gibt
viele gemeinsame interessen felder
dienen bestimmt angegangen werden und
man muss eben auch bei der sprachwahl
aufhören über identitätspolitik über
gegensätze zwischen dem westen und osten
zu sprechen denn diese gegensätze wir
sind meiner meinung nach in den letzten
30 40 jahren auch zum großen teil
abgebaut und es interessiert
interessiert die menschen auf der
strasse nicht die menschen möchten ein
gutes leben haben die möchten die
menschen möchten dass es ihren kindern
besser geht als wie es ihnen geht und
das ist glaube ich das interesse der
mensch daran sollte man sich orientieren
sowohl in der türkei als auch in europa
und dazu gibt es so viele felder wo man
zusammenarbeiten kann
ja jeder ganz kurz zum schluss im moment
gibt dass er die die strategischen
interessen gehen ja weit auseinander sie
haben es ja auch skizziert gibt es da
eine möglichkeit jetzt gerade auch in
geopolitisch betrachtet östliches
mittelmeer südostflanke der nato auch
die interessen der türkei aber auch die
interessen der anderen nato-staaten dass
man da wieder einmal näher zusammen
kommt
vielleicht in der kurzen antwort
in den vereinigten staaten in der
europäischen union ist ja wie man aus
der eigenen interessenlage anreize
schaffen kann für kooperation seitens
der türkischen regierung und es ist eben
nicht die türkische zivilgesellschaft
mit der man verhandelt sondern es ist
die türkische regierung die ihre
ressourcen mobilisiert und politik
treibt aber alles endet damit mit der
frage was ist wenn die türkische
regierung dies nicht annimmt wenn
präsident erdogan auf dieses angebot
nicht eingeht und dann heißt das müssten
rote linien gezogen werden da sollte man
sehr vorsichtig sein diese roten linien
sind ein gefährliches spiel weil man
eben die türkei als zukünftigen partner
nicht verlieren will gut dann bedanke
ich mich für die diskussion bei allen
voran bei günter seufert bei mustafa
rolle und bei thomas jäger liebe
zuschauer bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]